So the next game against
exhibit has already been played x times,
so yes, this strange A3
variant, no one understands what it's supposed to
be good for, there's
also the
well, well,
normal development should
actually be enough to suit me properly,
yes runner G4, that's an idea,
my B7
But it depends on whether he really wants to take it,
okay, you know, you just want to
play some total nonsense,
regardless of whether it's somehow good now or
somehow has an idea or whatever.
Knight C3 can also be
done like this. Knight Bishop
Check
Check like this is now  Of course, a
little bit of caution is still
recommended, but maybe
here instead of D4, no, then I can
also take away C4. Queen H6 is
always such a
problem here, so now I can
also play D with D6.
Knights
threaten the 3
J yes C2
depends on
chess and then at speed to have tower C3
okay check yes let's take it with us too so
now the idea of ​​tower E5 or tower
F5
I'll take that with me again here I can
still play tower D6 E6 and so white white
just stands
So stupid,
I think I have
weaknesses everywhere, the fpawns H4 B5, so
practically everything is somehow
weak,
hm. Let's
see if we can come up for the second
row.
Well, it's super clear that we do
n't like it either, but I don't see how else I
would like to move on  Now try here with the
queen's
pawn wars,
it also depends on
check
so I just have to be careful he ca
n't get a passed pawn here that is
supported by the rooks,
that could get really
unpleasant very quickly
but  It's not that easy to win here
anyway
with the idea of
E5 to get all the pawns
away, so now he can't
beat E5 because C5 then
hangs, I'll win the two pawns
somehow now, so well
maybe he'll get one
for it, I think  sometimes a little bit
after that's pleasant you don't have such a
huge
time disadvantage
Check
time
warning
oh you could have just taken it
Check yes win it has now become really difficult in position
Check it could also be quite risky
what I'm doing here no
Check Check Check Check
Check
okay, yes, that was fine, I think. I have
no idea if we
looked really bad, but then I did
n't get any further